[Music]
water is amazing it's necessary for life
to exist makes you healthier and it's
incredibly refreshing especially after
an intense workout but is water
intoxication a real thing
can you drink too much water we're often
told to drink around 8 glasses of water
a day to stay healthy but the honest
truth is that this specific number is
somewhat arbitrary and no scientific
research exists to support it regardless
we know water is incredibly important in
fact every organism we know if requires
water to survive not only does it help
the human body to bring oxygen and
nutrients to the cells regulate body
temperatures and aid metabolism but it
flushes waste out of the body sweat out
too much during a sporting event and
you'll start to feel a bit woozy 3 days
without water and you likely won't
survive so how could such an essential
substance hurt us it all comes down to
the cellular level the water you drink
has very few electrolytes in it things
like sodium or potassium especially
compared to your cells
the electrolytes in your cells allow
your muscles and nerves to work properly
and help to control blood pressure and
blood volume without them your body
cannot function now normally the
difference in electrolyte concentration
inside and outside the cell wouldn't
pose a problem because your kidneys
flush out any excess water
however the kidneys can only excrete
fluid at a certain rate this means that
consuming a lot of water in a short
period of time creates a large
concentration difference as a result
water is drawn into the cells in an
attempt to dilute the concentration and
even out the proportion of electrolytes
and this causes the cells to swell the
problem is unlike other parts of your
body the brain literally has no room
inside the skull for these newly plumped
cells this results in extreme headaches
and confusion leading to seizures comas
respiratory arrest
and even death so should you be worried
not likely cases of water intoxication
are very rare though they do happen in
extreme circumstances
close to 1/6 of marathon runners develop
mild cases in their careers with all
endurance athletes at a higher risk this
is because under the extremes of
athletic stress the body attempts to
conserve water so not only are you
taking more water in you're peeing less
out science says though you're not
likely to suffer from water intoxication
you should drink to your thirst it's the
best indicator
don't forget we have a new video out
every day during the Olympics but if you
can't wait and head to the cbc.ca slash
olympics slash sign says for more keep
asking those burning questions with the
hashtag science says and subscribe for
more awesome science videos
[Music]